[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 les invités une
émission dédiée à celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département et
aujourd'hui jeudi 9 mars parole à
nicolas boukhrief le réalisateur dont le
dernier film vient tout juste de sortir
au cinéma la confession un film inspiré
d'un roman et qui raconte l'histoire
d'amour complexe entre un homme d'église
une femme communistes nous l'avons
rencontré lors de l'avant-première à
versailles parole aussi dans cette
émission à main n'ont jamais présidente
de l'association jury ce tribut d'une
association étudiante est implantée à
lui vécu et qui propose ce vendredi la
reconstitution du procès de jacques
merino tribunal de grande instance de
versailles
la confession c'est donc le nom du
nouveau film du cinéaste nicolas
boukhrief sorti hier dans les salles
obscures il s'agit d'une adaptation
excusez moi du livre léon morin prêtre
de béatrice beck
l'histoire d'amour entre un prêtre et
une communiste athée nous avons
rencontré le réalisateur il ya quelques
jours à versailles lors d'une avant
première on écoute au micro de camille
lambert à l'orgue à nouveau prêtre en
vie avec les formidables et les comment
il est jeune
moi c'est surtout sa voix que j'ai
apprécié lorsque vous manqués d'hommes
qu'il arrive à tous vous assumez comme
ça c'est tout c'est mon parle pour toi
ces biens détenus
c'est un an et demi que je suis ici vous
croyez en fait ça fait 20 ans que je
faire ce film
depuis j'ai découvert le livre de
béatrice beck j'ai eu envie d'adapter
cet ouvrage au cinéma qu'elle a déjà été
adapté plusieurs fois d'ailleurs une
fois en chine il faut un téléfilm et je
pensais que cette histoire était très
actuel une histoire d'amour
on va dire impossible entre un prêtre
agent communiste pendant la guerre c'est
un sujet en or il y avait deux rôles
forcément modifié pour des acteurs vous
avez tous les les éléments clés d'un
grand nombre de radios et au centre
émotion spiritualité la question qui
sous-tend sims et qu'est ce que c'est
que damien la fox a quitté la base du
nez de bec et j'ai essayé de respecter
traduire dans bon début dans le film tel
que je vais fait en fait après il est
clair que le le contexte va garder car
en crée une tension naturelle et
immédiat que ça c'est plutôt très bien
et après il y avait deux personnages les
dialogues qui était tellement beau dans
le mur que je trouvais assez
passionnante
de le reprendre et de développer et
proposer à deux comédiens au report
vendent bien et c'est quoi votre avis
que toute religion est une forme de
lâcheté
tiens donc il faut que ça passe que les
uns montent à monter l'émotion de dieu
pour conjurer leur peur de la mort
elle-même qu'il ya derrière
vous pensez que j'ai pas peur de mourir
tout moment d'autres on voyait plus
courageux je le suis personne ne peut
dire ce qu'il ressentira au moment de
son dernier soupir et moi pas plus qu'un
autre
c'est un film sur quelle voie peu prend
d'amour pour s'exprimer
comment commandes de personnes peuvent
se rencontrer quand les interdits en
sont absolus c'est pour ça que tenait
d'ailleurs à ce que le personnage
féminin soit non pas veuve comme dans le
roman mais un mari prisonnier à
prisonniers de guerre
je trouvais ça plus intéressant parce
que ça mettait les deux personnages sur
un pied d'égalité c'est pas et sort
d'une jeune femme
disponible et d'un prêtre qui ne met pas
ses seules deux personnes qui sont
engagés moralement chacune à sa manière
cet engagement moral leur permet pas de
vivre cette histoire de façon classique
on va dire d'où l'intérêt cette histoire
avec son originalité
on m'a guéri ses marines bâton des
acteurs prêts fin mais je pardonne
physiquement y compris dans leur jeu
notre société mais aussi physiquement et
je trouvais que faire un saut
d'orchestre de deux violons et se sortir
les violons comme comme on dit on
m'aurait paru finalement assez vulgaire
pour l'histoire je vais traiter j'ai
trouvé que cette nappe comme ça dans le
verbe me paraissent plus délicate et
plus au service du récit
quand j'écris un scénario mais je
cherchais peu à peu dans les acteurs
français qu'elle était celui qui me
paraissait idéal pour le rôle
comme j'avais l'idée d'un an morin très
aérien n'a personnage très aérien très
dense en trés céleste j'ai envie de dire
une idée de romain duris que je
connaissais pas mais que je ne
m'excuserai et vous tout de suite et je
lui ai proposé le rôle de lundi m'a dit
oui le mercredi donc il a dû sentir que
les tromper par en fait probablement
dans l'intuition que j'avais qui
pouvaient parfaitement jouer ce rôle et
donc il a il a accepté très rapidement à
partir de là il a fallu trouver sa
partenaire là c'était notre l'autre
démarche et j'ai vu une quarantaine de
comédienne plus ou moins connus d et le
choix s'est porté sur marine vacth parce
que j'ai senti qu'elle avait la maturité
et la la puissance nécessaire pour
pouvoir aborder un rôle aussi important
dit il était totalement harmonieux ils
ont trouvé tout soudain de l'oedt impôts
de leurs échanges et ça a été un
tournage de ce point de vue là qu'ils
avaient une forme de grâce car les deux
acteurs disait ce texte
quand même très précis et très écrit le
disait qu'une naturel et l'évidence et
une fluidité qui est proprement
fascinant
tu pourras pas manquer
ce que vous mentez qu'elle fois à la
fois c'est un soldat allemand un de ceux
qui passent dans votre église bien
compte pas me suis lavé
j'aurais trouvé les mots pour me
convertis c'est être faux qui finira
t-on faire changer d'avis on continue ce
7,8 les invités avec manon jamais
président de l'association juris tribune
bonsoir ça l'association étudiante juris
tribune qui propose du coup demain
vendredi 10 mars la reconstitution au
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles du procès de jacques mesrine
un procès qui s'est tenu au mois de mai
1977 et il ya 40 ans on va continuer ou
un petit peu ma non jamais
quand on parle de reconstitution parle
de poids concrètement à ce que ça veut
dire que vous allez reprendre mot pour
mot ce qui a été dit le jour du du
procès ou pendant les trois semaines
plus tôt du procès est ce que tout est
figé tout est quadrillée déjà alors
quand on reconstitue un peu ce procès on
essaye d'être le plus proche de la
réalité
donc on a repris des éléments de
journaux télévisés des éléments de média
papier des livres notamment le livre de
jacques meriem qu'il avait écrit pendant
ces trois semaines de procès et le livre
de son associé en quelque sorte qu'ils
étaient michel ardouin aussi dit le
porte avions pour ceux qui connaissent
et ensuite on va par exemple la étant
donné la longueur du procès le nombre de
témoins qui a eu on a été obligés de
raccourcir un peu de plaisir les témoins
clés dont c'était trois semaines mais
vous c'est une après midi sa r6 or ce
qui est assez long et c'est du un vrai
travail d'investigation finalement il ya
un vrai travail de recherche de
chercheurs à faire sur le procès sur le
personnage aussi j'imagine oui bah
finalement il faut continuer toute la
personnalité du personnage pour que
l'acteur puisse un petit peu se remettre
dans sa peau il refaire ce que le
personnage avait fait puisque jacques
mesrine dans son procès était assez
exceptionnel là on voit quelques images
ailleurs d'autres reconstitution puisque
c'est pas la première fois que vous
faites ça non évidemment le choix de
jacques mary c'est pourquoi c'est pour
les 40 ans du procès c'est parce que
c'est un personnage qui a marqué qui
peut aussi fasciné c'est parce que en
fait finalement
jusqu'ici on avait toujours fait des
procès qui traitait de meurtre et on
s'est dit bon pourquoi pas cette année
on va donner un nouveau visage du droit
pénal donc là on va avoir des braquages
des prises d'otages dure celle du port
d'armes prohibées donc beaucoup de
choses
et finalement on va voir une technique
pénale très intéressante pour les
étudiants et surtout à la c1 personnes
ce qui personnellement me fascine et
aujourd'hui je suis aussi la responsable
du projet on est évidemment mais jean
leva connu malheureusement mais c'est
vrai que je crois que c'était un
personnage très intéressant avec une
personnalité complexe et beaucoup
d'éléments qui voit là donner un
caractère un peu exceptionnel je trouve
à ce procès du coup quelqu'un va
incarner jacques jacques merino doit pas
être un rôle facile aussi c'est un
travail de comédien presse que sa
demande ait beaucoup de travail pour
cette personne en question c'est un
homme c'est un homme c'est un étudiant
du coup c'est quelqu'un de l'association
pour qui j'ai dû écrire tous les
dialogues
donc il ya eu aussi un peu comme un
travail de scénariste finalement en
écrivant tous ses discours les
didascalies pour qu'ils puissent un peu
savoir ce qu'il allait faire
alors il travaille expliqué nous sans
nous dévoiler le procès la
reconstitution qui se tiendra demain
quels étaient les particularités du
procès de jacques mesrine en 1977 40 ans
auparavant alors lors de ce procès
jacques mérine il était quand même très
grand seigneur c'est vraiment ce qu'on
retient de lui c'est ce que les
magistrats 10 10 les magistrats disent
c'est ce que les policiers on dit
notamment lors de ces arrestations quand
ils pariaient des caisses de champagne
sur sa future évasion notamment après
son arrestation à boulogne billancourt
hélas qu'on va vraiment retrouvé c'est
le fait que jacques mérine coupe tout le
temps les témoins mais de manière à
faire rigoler le public
c'est un show s'en fout un peu un show
c'est vraiment un très grand acteur est
donc là on a essayé de reproduire un
petit peu ce caractère
chez le personnage et il y aura
évidemment de grosses surprises puisque
il faut savoir qui c'est passé qu'elle
aime beaucoup de choses lors de ce
procès que vous allez devoir vous
pendant 16 heures
oui et confondant si du coup c'est une
découverte pour vous tous demain après
midi au loria une répétition générale un
peu comme une théorie une première
répétition avec juste les témoins les
avocats et la présidente du tribunal
et ensuite la demain matin avant la
reconstitution en elle-même
on a une ré dernière répétition pour que
tout le monde soit bien à l'aise qu'ils
aient le temps de se mettre un petit peu
dans le dans le contexte et surtout dans
le lieu parce que c'est vrai que c'est
très impressionnant quand on est
étudiant de se retrouver dans une salle
d'assises devant un public puisqu'il ya
c'est important parce qu'il ya quand
même environ 100 places chaque année ça
la salle d'audience et et rencontres
voilà donc pourquoi selon vous ça
intéresse des gens sérieux constitution
parce que vous êtes bonjour ou parce que
même si c'est ça après c'est surtout le
fait de se retrouver voilà il ya une
vraie cohésion entre professeurs chargés
de td
c'est un moment assez exceptionnel parce
que finalement on va se mettre dans la
peau de nos futurs métiers ou même de
personnages qu'on n'aurait pu côtoyer ou
c'est vraiment qu'il ya un moment
exceptionnel il ya des charges et eli
qui viennent juste pour y assister il ya
parfois même des professeurs dans le
public donc c'est vraiment un grand
moment de cohésion je pense que c'est
aussi pour ça que ça plaît beaucoup
vous parliez de vous pour vous en tant
qu étudiant en droit
quel est l'intérêt de faire une
reconstitution j'imagine c'est pas
uniquement un jeu même s'il doit être
assez enivrant de de faire jacques
merino fictif qu'il est l'intérêt pour
vous c'est de vous mettre dans des
vraies conditions c'est plutôt 8 2
semaines voilà dans la condition de
l'avocat d'un procès parce que
finalement on n'a pas forcément beaucoup
l'occasion d'aller au tribunal ou en
cour d'assises où même en cours
je dirais qu'ils vont découvrir pour la
première fois peut-être un tribunal
aussi mais si c'est important grégory
quand on fait des études de droit
et puis même quand y'en a qui sont juré
ça leur donne aussi le côté voilà
travailler avec un magistrat qui l'a est
un professeur du coup marié ma boursiers
qui est vice doyen de la faculté et qui
est professeur en droit pénal en 2e
année donc ça leur donne aussi ce côté
travaille avec le magistrat tout le
dialogue qui se fait à côté donc après
les plaidoiries pour savoir quelle
sentence on va appliquer à l'accusé donc
ça ça change un peu de choses qu'on ne
pourrait pas vivre en tant qu'étudiant
donc demain hors public c'est à peu près
une vingtaine de personnes qui vont
intervenir pendant pendant six heures
dont vous le lisiez des chargés de td ce
que ça rajoute un peu de pression est ce
qu'on a peut-être peur pour s'approcher
une copie si on a été mauvais au bond où
ça n'a rien à voir non on arrive à
sortir du bureau le prof élève
finalement on arrive quand même bien à
sortir du rôle profs-élèves parce que
les charges et l'été sont jeunes
donc il ya quand même une certaine
proximité et puis souvent ils sont très
connus
on est quand même très très proches de
nos professeurs et de nos charges était
donc c'est vraiment plus à un vrai
plaisir de partager ce moment où il ya
eu beaucoup de moments de rigolade
notamment au moment des réunions quand
tu veux changer tes et non mais attendez
moi je veux que vous disiez ça pour
m'aider et on avait un autre qui
répondait non un an plus tôt ça pour
m'aider moi série cas voilà il ya
vraiment une complicité entre les
charges et aider les professeurs et les
étudiants qui seront là et vous en tant
que présidente de l'association tout
sera votre rôle demain demain je serai
assesseurs et ce sera aussi le
la coordination mon équipe tout au long
du projet et du procès et ce alors c'est
très impressionnant
dernière précision pour ceux qui sont
éventuellement intéressés c'est à partir
de 13 heures au tribunal de grande
instance de versailles tout le monde
puis accéder c'est réservé aux étudiants
de la faculté de lever est ce qu ou
alors comment ça se passe où l'on peut y
accéder il faut juste sa carte
d'identité et après pc faut se presser
oui parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
place et une fois que la salle est
complète il ya plus de possibilité de
rentrer maintenant voilà il faut arriver
entre 12h30 et 13h quand les portes sous
faulx est très rapide pour avoir les
meilleures places au premier rang devant
le tribunal enfin au tribunal de grande
instance de versailles merci manon
desriac d'être venu en plateau ou
d'avoir répondu à nos questions bonne
chance aussi pour le principe demain
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
ce soir prochain rendez vous lundi 10 il
a retrouvé toutes nos séquences en
replay sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]
m